*clap*
*explosion*
Meme Review
Say it with me kids "MEME REVIEW"
*clap*
Clap it with me parents "MEME REVIEW"
Everyone's favorite huee~-
Show
Welcome back everyone
To your highlight of the week
"Meme Review"
YouTube show
*cough*
*drinking G Fuel*
Aww, out of G Fuel?!
What the freak!
Alright, i'm gonna try and compose my self
despite the fact that i'm out of G...
God I mean...
Now, we're gonna start this awkwards some wonderful Minecraft memes
Y'all know this would come up this week
if you are fellow memester
Like I am
this Minecraft memes are just blowing up!
*cough*
*ughm*
Now, i really like this Minecraft memes
it's kinda surprises me that no one's done this before
the heck
I mean that's good
that's good
it's a good meme
makes you laugh
haha
and isn't that really what memes all comes down to
a good old haha
Alright
who's it going to be
ok, armor
helmet
ah
64?!
Oh my God!
See
See what I mean?
It's a nice meme
Oh my god, that rhymed
I don't like this one though
Don't like this one
DELETE THIS ONE!
Get it out of my sight!
Peter Griffin will never be Sans
PETER GRIFFIN WILL NEVER BE SANS!
I'm so done
I'm just absolutely done!
Okay?!
What the f~-
an egg?!
Okay that's funny
Eggs are funny
This is How to Basic him alright?
everyone....
Alright take it back
that's just disgusting
I'm sorry H3H3
I'm not calling you out
Or anything...
What else do we got, okay
See what I mean, it's a good meme
It makes you laugh
It makes you go haha
Very nice, I like it
That's a strong dog
Not supposed to give my opinion
Where's the PewDiePie one, where I don't have any legs
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
RACISM!....
look at this one with Bob Ross though
That's great
So cute
Alright, I haven't seen this one
Two buckets?
That's great
What a great meme
I'm gonna rate it
What?
We still have more memes??
Okay, freak yeah!
The four Horsemen of the Minepocalypse
If you've seen any of these
then you best be on making great haste
Cuz my God, they cannot defeated!
Goddamn
Oh look at that
I knew it
racism
Stop being goddamn bigoted
Jesus Croist
I'm gonna rate the Minecraft meme
it's solid 7 everyone!
Next meme
*clap*
*epic explosion*
Now, I think it's worth mentioning just powerful the Ricardo memes
despite me reviewing them last week
Ricardo memes is still going
Very strong
when you change height you on tinder
from 5'11
to 6'0 inches
goddamn
Holy frik!
Top 10 reasons
why i hate wide dog
numberf
Number 5
he's ugly and fat
don't talk about my boi wide dog
No one:
Russian dashcam videos:
These memes, are just freaking everywhere
First to all
why so many Russian dashcam videos
No one:
Russian Dashcam videos:
This is not even Russia
This is San Andreas
What the freak
No one:
Russian dashcam videos:
How did freaky the tickity does that even happen?
C'mon Russia
get your act together
are you okay?
i like how Russia you're allowed to say that
that no one cares but if i went india
Oh my God
How could you said that?!
now of course it's meme, is a variation of the literally no one
XYZ or whatever like
No one:
YouTubers:
Stop attacking a YouTubers
It's really hard being a YouTubers, okay?
so just stop it
i feel personally offended by this
Now, moving back to
No one:
Russian dashcam videos:
What the frik!
What is happening in Russia everyone?
i especially like this one
No one:
Xbox players:
*bzzzz*
he he he he
No one:
T-Series Subscribers
*bzzzz*
I know
I can make memes too
Nobody:
Russian dashcam videos:
are you even trying at this point
like, just new footages
G Fuel powder *Exists*
PewDiePie
This is  my last and final weapon againts T-Series
i didn't want to reveal my power this early in the game
I have
A really large
tongue
watch carefully T-series
are you seeing this T-Series?
thet's right T-Series
i think i've proved my point here today
i expect you
to run back
and never look back
never come back from you're banished
from these lands T-Series
Now, of course don't forget to enter the code:
PewDiePie
for 10% G Fuel
it is very delish
Nobody:
Anime character with glasses:
I really like this memes
I don't know why adding nobody in front of joke to make funny of some reason
Literally no one:
Egyptian:
You want pyramids?!
No one:
YouTubers reacting to something:
Hey, wait a minute
stop it right there!
Her: do you eat ass?
Me:
allright, well
so bad, Jesus Crist
Parent: why are you falling your classes?
Me:
*bzzzz*
*clap*
it's funny because it's relatable for you
you dumbballs
Nobody:
*burp*
Taiwanese dashcam videos:
damn
Taiwanese came out of nowhere
put Russia to shame
goddamn
Allright, guys
smash like and subscribe if you're Taiwanese
and here's a special brofist
for my Taiwanese bros
Absolutely no one:
N-word who post late-night Bart Simpson edits:
"I'm not happy at all!"
It's funny
because it's true get it?
No one:
YouTubers using a $15,000 PC to play Fornite:
stop attacking YouTubers
okay?
yeah i need  a $15,000 computers to record myself reacting to memes
any other questions?
b*tch
now, this is actualy a wonderful
meme template
of Bill Gates that can lead to other wonderful creation
such as this one
Anime boobs
the bra
it's funny
because it's true
Using a calculator to make sure 4+3 equals 7 on a test
it's funny because it's relatable for idiots
not me of course
i know that's....
seven
you can just add this to literally anything, about this one
Nobody:
brie Larson
it's a personal attack or something?
literally know what
see, i can make jokes too
Nobody:
Brie Larson: is this some kinda personal attack
DAMN IT THAT WAS MY JOKE!
*break*
Alright
*clap*
This meme get a 7.5
i actually realy like this